this is where it starts to get
interesting okay we've rotated at once
and we've gotten in the same shape in
the same place but that's not the only
way you can rotate it same Center
asymmetry but I could choose a different
angle
anyone would have suggest another angle
Morgan say yeah 270 okay let's do 270 I
have a over here okay 270 degrees I need
more colors I wonder if you've got a few
there as well
270 degrees if I have air to here I
think it's gonna go all the way around
to here this will be a two I guess picks
up rotated different way in the same way
this B right is gonna go all the way
around and it's gonna come over here
right that'll be be sued you can see why
the colors are gonna be home because
this is it okay you see it's gonna
happen you're gonna get C to fear D to
keep but importantly now getting mind
sort of rainbow in the t-square I have
the same shape in the same place okay
makes sense okay now I keep doing this
there are other ways to do it so here's
the important thing to do I can rotate
this a certain number of times to get
same shape in the same place okay that
number of times is called the order of
symmetry this is a really important
phrase to get down the order of symmetry
just like a shake could have many axes
of symmetry it can have many orders of
symmetry okay let me show you um we
didn't or some of you I think when you
see actually got to explore this last
time right but I have a bit of a
conundrum for you okay watch this I
showed you this shape yesterday I said
if you follow the paper once and then
you do the cut okay you get how many
axes of symmetry
an accident she's just that straight
line that I would draw and it would
correspond to that fault
wouldn't it okay cool one fold one exit
century okay now if I were to fold it
again side for once and fold it twice
and then make a cut you get a shape like
this know how many axes of symmetry I
can see well measuring carefully I think
you can see two is one here in fact if
you look carefully you can see the fold
and this one here ah hold on a second
one fold one axis of surgery two folds
to exit of symmetry three folds what
would three folds give you here a couple
of different guesses I hear three is six
my guess would be one fold one axis to
folding two axes three folds I would
guess three axes but you don't get free
now I'll tell you because I've counted
already there are four axial symmetry
keep part of the puzzle for you is and I
want you have think about this and come
back to me later
why did their form and not three not six
anyway but my point is many axis
symmetry for reflection many orders of
symmetry or rotation okay let me show
you how you work out what sort of one
how many orders of symmetry something
has because you know how you did that
tasks before it's like cut the numbers
of orders of axes surgery you'll do the
same with rotational symmetry okay so
let me show you
Shh we're doing tensional symmetry the
shade would which can be rotated and it
still looks the same
that's what this definition means how
many matches there are as you go around
that's what we were doing here 90
degrees and subsidiaries that's what you
call the order so watch this shape here
okay see this shape it has two orders of
symmetry
I'll show you what let's rotate it watch
carefully I'll do it twice so you catch
it but watch rotates once
rotates twice stay with me cuz this is
tricky
let me show you again one rotation two
rotations so there are two orders of
symmetry but have a look at the next
shape you can almost see it punch you
okay
let's press rotate on it watch how many
times it rotates once twice three times
three orders of symmetry okay now a nice
way to think about this is a great arm
illustration here is think about
propellers yes right this is exactly
what I like to think about is yep
propeller blades okay war propeller
blades means a higher order okay and you
can see the more blades you have you get
this is what Noah's [ __ ] back look
see it has eight bits off it right okay
now unfortunately for us fortunately
unfortunately reflectional symmetry is
really easy to make because you fall
stuff you cut it it works okay if you
fall stuff and cut it there's no way you
can fold it to get rotational symmetry
because folding does not rotate things
folding reflects things okay but thanks
to technology I am going to show you
what it would look like if we did okay
now how to look with me this is gonna
draw it's going to make a shape with a
particular order symmetry whatever ID
screws so we'll start with two okay I've
asked you a second why by the way why
isn't one the lowest order why is
through the lowest order you have to
think about it
watch okay I'm going to draw a shape and
then this this little app is going to
make it rotationally symmetrical for me
okay so watch like I've got a
touchscreen
it's so cool hey go okay so they have
let's see given us Emily have a look you
see what I've got
if I were to take this shape and rotate
it around I could rotate it once and
then I could rotate it again to what is
the symmetry yeah make sense let me do
another one let's go let's go three
orders of symmetry okay let's try this
how's that can you see again 300
symmetry I can spin it around here and
then these tacky bits will line up on
here and they'll line up again and
they'll line up back where they started
three orders of symmetry shall we do
nine everyone wants to do nine this is
fun okay here we go
what shall I make kind of like a flower
hey now by the way do you remember at
the very beginning of this topic I said
to you that symmetry has to do with
beauty do you remember that does that
not have sort of a character surgery it
looks like a flower doesn't have we all
confess hold on let me let me see if I
can hold up my hand for you so you can
see what I'm doing okay watch one thing
go okay watch
okay so in summary in summary rotational
symmetry it's so much like reflectional
symmetry but it's also quite different
isn't it it's got its got orders instead
of axes okay and then you can make cool
stuff like that